i appreciate you talking to me about
this i had so much fun with this movie
darby i'm curious for you i mean when
this project came your way what got you
interested in doing it had you been
familiar with this character at all or
was this brand new to you with the
script
i definitely knew who emily elizabeth
was and clifford of course and i loved
the tv show when i was younger and the
books um and when i found out they're
doing a live action i was like that's
this is going to be really cool and so
um i read the script and i was like this
is
perfect to you know it's perfect and
it's a story of clifford no one's heard
before but it
is um something i think everyone's going
to love because it's just like a new
addition to the classic story and it's
set in new york too which is a perfect
city for him in a big city for a big dog
and so i'm excited just for everyone to
see anything jack what did you like
about uncle casey was there anything
particularly fun about playing him were
there aspects of him you hadn't really
gotten to explore in a character before
i think uh yeah he was so much fun to
play um this kind of uh slightly uh
foolish man-child who's in this sort of
perpetual state of arrested development
and that was certainly you know the type
of character that i could recognize uh
an element of myself in um but i really
liked as well that he kind of goes on a
bit of a journey over the course of the
film and you know
he he certainly kind of matures and and
and steps up to the plate in terms of
being a little bit more responsible and
realizing that that's not as scary as he
thought um and you know also for me like
the opportunity to to play and to um
have you know those elements of physical
comedy and those big comic set pieces um
you know i absolutely love uh getting my
teeth into those so yeah it was so much
fun to play so then jack who would you
say is harder to work with dwayne
johnson on jungle cruise or clifford a
giant red dog
uh
i would say uh you know both have
similar challenges uh clifford was um on
set operated by like two puppets it was
the
two like puppeteers in this kind of ten
foot animatronic red um uh puppet
clifford and that's what we were acting
uh opposite um and yeah on jungle cruise
dwayne is also a puppet he's operated by
i think there's three guys in there on
each other's shoulders and they operate
the arms and stuff and then they cgi him
in afterwards
uh so yeah i'm now the go-to guy if you
need uh someone to act opposite cgi
i love you guys as a comedy duo you're
absolutely delightful together
did you form a bond with each other
pretty instantly did it take some time
to figure out that rhythm because i just
i could watch the two of you guys
together all day
well i think what first helped us bond
uh was that we realized we had a shared
love of uh the
musical ubra of one direction
um and so there was a lot of one
direction played um
and whilst that started out as the thing
that bonded us uh in the end it was also
the thing that nearly um fractured our
relationship beyond repair because uh
derby
had a pawn shop for playing one
direction at six o'clock in the morning
in the makeup trailer and whilst i love
1d and i'm very much part of the fandom
at six o'clock i think i'm possibly less
of a fan than darby is um and also there
was some you know it was every day for
three months i maybe loved one direction
when i started this film and at the end
i think i was possibly
um more into the jonas brothers
they're good too i guess
so darby what is your side of the story
i mean one direction i just
i'll always be a fan of one direction no
matter how much i hear their music but i
mean
it's fine i guess i mean i guess it was
six o'clock in the morning but yeah from
the table read the day we met we made
fast friends and the whole set which is
a fun
you know um
just warm
family everyone on set of clifford and
just we all made fast friends and
and yeah we still keep in touch this day
and talk every now and then
and we and darby's mom and dad were on
set who i get on with very well and that
helped it feel like a family and we kept
my head away from the set which would
have obviously not made it feel like a
family because he would have been grumpy
all the time and been a real sour
atmosphere so i made sure he wasn't
anywhere near the set and i really hoped
darby could you have ever imagined that
you'd be doing a car chase scene where
you were the one driving at your age
i never would have guessed i mean i mean
ever since i was younger i've always
wanted to do a car chase scene like i
just thought that was so cool and i
always been interested in like that
would be so cool just to like drive a
car just like go for go for it you know
like in a car chase oh that was so cool
so once i was finally a part of one i
felt so honored and grateful that i got
to i was like oh my gosh i'm gonna get
to drive the moving van let's go i get
set and i don't actually get to drive it
i get to sit in the driver's seat and
pretend like i'm driving and i was a
little bit disappointed
but it's okay because it was hooked up
to the trailer and then people would
walk by on the street and look in to the
van and be like is that a child in the
driver's seat of a moving truck and i'd
be like oh yeah don't worry it is but um
i'm not actually driving sadly but i
think i think for safety reasons it was
okay that i wasn't driving
but um i think that was all um also like
one of my favorite scenes
jack what was it like to get to shoot
the big fat scene in the deli and pretty
much pick up and throw anything you
could at bad guys
uh yeah i mean that was so much fun that
was a scene that we spent a lot of time
choreographing with the stance
department and it suddenly just in the
middle of the movie turns into a jackie
chan film it was great fun to to shoot
um and yeah uh they basically gave me
free reign of that deli and said uh use
whatever props you like
and we really took that and ran with it
um and i even had my little homage to
salt bay which i uh threw in at the end
of the fight as well in the hope that
saltbae sees it and if i go and eat at
his restaurant i can get you know 50
discount off his 700 stakes
did anybody get injured during that like
what was that
like to shoot how long did that take to
do
uh yeah i think there were i mean
no fortunately no one got injured but
you know we were we were acting with
props that it's quite it's quite hard to
injure someone when you're attacking
them with a pickle uh so yeah there was
uh there was a few kind of like mishaps
and i think it was a nightmare for the
continuity department to try and work
out what had been thrown and uh who had
been hit with what but uh yeah it all
edited together nicely in the end and
it's actually one of my favorite
sequences in the film you know it has
derby and the truck and then me running
away from the bad guys and yeah we
really enjoyed filming that scene
well thank you guys for talking to me
about it i thought it was just
delightful and fun so thank you so much
you